olá olá
e é agenda 2030 traz para gente hoje um
desafio na área da saúde que é talvez um
desafio que deixe as pessoas pensando
como vou conseguir erradicar até 2030
tuberculose hiv e hepatites virais
eu perco losi é uma doença tão antiga
quanto a história da humanidade mas ela
tem cura em tratamento tem cura fazendo
acompanhamento dá tudo certo a repetir
de ser gente a gente conseguiu a cura em
3 meses meu paciente com a partir de
seis está curado e vai embora feliz do
consultório só que é para te ver e hiv
não tem cura a mas eles estão falando
sobre a cura do hiv recentemente então é
disso que você veio falar não não vim
falar sobre a cura do hiv apesar de ser
um sonho muito grande de todos os
pacientes que passam por mim lá no
hospital universitário eu ainda não
posso realizar esse sonho deles mas eu
vim falar de uma coisa que atrapalha o
tratamento deles
em quantas vezes no seu dia a dia você
fala sobre hiv vocês que tem filhos já
falaram sobre hiv com eles e com seus
amigos na sua roda no barzinho na
festinha já falaram sobre hiv
e no seu trabalho quantas pessoas
vivendo com hiv vocês conhecem
é sim tem alguém que conhece alguém
vivendo com hiv aqui com a gente hoje
em algumas pessoas sim mas eu vou te
dizer eu tenho certeza que todos vocês
aqui hoje conhecem alguém vivendo com
hiv só que vocês não sabem disso e vocês
não sabem disso por uma razão muito
simples essas pessoas precisam se
esconder e por que uma pessoa hoje
vivendo com hiv sendo que uma doença que
tem tratamento ela não é transmissível
quando você controla o vírus porque
essas pessoas precisam se esconder
precisam se esconder para fazer um teste
rápido numa unidade de saúde precisam se
esconder para ir ter uma consulta comigo
precisam se esconder para buscar o
remédio para fazer exames
é porque nós que não temos hiv somos
preconceituosos então eu vim falar que a
maneira da gente é erradicar essas
doenças na verdade é mudar uma coisa que
vem junto com a gente há muitos anos o
preconceito você talvez deve tá pensando
eu não tenho preconceito essa pessoa
trabalha comigo que risco que ela me
oferece não é de fato não te oferece
risco nenhum mas e se você descobrisse
que seu parceiro ou sua parceira tem hiv
hoje você tá casado ou no relacionamento
estável e aí seu parceiro chega para
você e te conta eu descobri que sou
soropositivo você continua com ele com a
primeira coisa que passa na sua cabeça e
se você pegasse o seu resultado positivo
hoje qual a primeira coisa que você
pensaria
é porque normalmente a gente pensa a hiv
existe mas está longe de mim não não
está longe de mim pode estar sentado
numa dessas cadeiras ao seu lado e você
não sabe porque essa pessoa não pode
contar que têm e vou te falar mais um
outro detalhe essa pessoa nem precisa te
contar que tem só que nos seus olhos de
quem tem preconceito com vírus você acha
que talvez ela seja uma ameaça para você
mas não é
e hoje o hiv ele tem tratamento ea
paciente ele entra no estado que a gente
chama de cura funcional que que é isso
enquanto ele estiver tomando as
medicações regularmente fazendo seus
exames ea carga viral estiver
indetectável trocando em miúdos não tem
vírus circulando no sangue dele ele não
contamina ninguém nem quem tem relação
sexual sem preservativo com ele ou com
ela
bom então por que que a gente tem
preconceito por uma razão muito simples
quem fala de hiv quem procura saber
sobre hiv hoje em dia só procura saber
sobre hiv quem tem ali ver quantas vezes
você entrou na internet para pesquisar o
assunto hiv talvez para um trabalho da
escola talvez porque passou alguma
propaganda na tv mas você hoje o dia
você não tem esse hábito e a gente só
tem preconceito com aquilo que a gente
não conhece então nós precisamos falar
sobre isso se a gente fala se a gente
traz conhecimento porque nós somos seres
da comunicação e é assim que a gente
constrói o nosso conhecimento vou contar
para vocês uma experiência do meu
consultório hoje a gente sabe que
epidemiologicamente a maior a faixa
etária que mais se contamina com vírus
hiv é entre 15
o anos e são os homens homens de 15 a 24
anos porque será que são os nossos
jovens que estão conectados nas mídias
sociais que tem contato com tudo quanto
é tipo de informação porque são eles que
pegam mais hiv porque eles não falam
sobre hiv ninguém fala sobre hiv com
eles a escola não fala mais os pais não
falam entre os amigos esse assunto não
existe
o que que aconteceu lá em 2015 entrou no
meu consultório um adolescente de 16
anos junto com a mãe
e os dois me procuraram para
recomendação de um outro colega porque
ele estava com ínguas no pescoço para os
caroços no pescoço e com uma febre e um
quadro de dengue que se arrastava por
mais de três meses
é o médico que me encaminhou já tinha
feito até biópsia dessas línguas achando
que o rapaz tinha câncer
e solicitou vários exames não falou nada
com a família a dose resultados e disse
procure uma infectologista vai lá no
consultório ela vai conversar com você
eles chegaram com os exames sem saber o
que o menino tinha isso eu sempre
pergunto como que eu posso te ajudar a
estou assim com esses caroços no pescoço
o médico pediu para fazer esses exames e
para procurar você eu vim aqui para ir
só você já olhou os exames sim mas eu
não entendo o que que tem neles tudo bem
quando eu falei os exames estava lá
teste de hiv reagente
e fechar os exames olhei para a carinha
dos dois estava mãe e o rapaz e falei
você sabia que seu exame de hiv positivo
perguntei assim
e o menino falou que não mamãe também
que não é o menino virou para mim falou
assim hiv mas o que que é isso
e o menino de 16 anos que estuda ele
tava na época no meio do ensino médio e
era bem estudioso um ano adiantado na
escola preocupado com fazer nem ele não
sabia que era hiv
e aí eu perguntei para ele na sequência
você teve alguma relação sexual
desprotegida ele olhou para a cara da
mãe dele disse não nunca tive relação a
mãe não ele vai da escola para casa de
casa para a escola só tudo bem terminei
a consulta solicitem mais alguns exames
expliquei o que que era hiv olha um
vírus que você pegou esses linfonodos
que estão aumentados no seu pescoço são
por causa disso e mas não se preocupa
porque tem tratamento e você não precisa
adoecer por conta disso é não precisa se
preocupar aí é aquele vírus da aids eu
falei é o vírus que causa a aids aí o
menino ficou triste olhou para baixo e
volta para mim falou assim doutor eu vou
viver quanto tempo
quem sabe é é complexo você dizer para
uma pessoa que tá no fim da vida quanto
tempo ela vai viver mas quando você vê
um jovem que ainda não fez nada da vida
te perguntar sobre fim de vida você para
o pensa nossa como eu gostaria que ele
soubesse que hiv não tem nada a ver com
fim de vida que é apenas mais uma coisa
que ele vai ter que se preocupar mas ele
não vai morrer disso afinal ela não se
preocupe quanto a isso porque dessa
doença eu tenho certeza que você não vai
morrer mas eu vou poder fazer a prova do
enem ou é melhor eu largar a escola e
curtir foi claro que não você vai fazer
a sua prova do enem normalmente mas ela
só talvez você não esteja acreditando em
mim porque você conhece pouco sobre a
doença também a gente nem sempre tem
tanto tempo para explicar o que é apesar
de eu dar nessa primeira consulta o
máximo de tempo possível para pessoa
o que se passa eu falei com ele continua
na escola
se você quer fazer o que eu quero fazer
o curso tal mas a sua prova do enem
segue como se nada tivesse acontecido
até aqui
e nós vamos iniciar a sua medicação e o
peço que você me de seis meses para a
gente voltar a falar de futuro novamente
porque você vai estar mais acostumado
com seu remédio com os exames e você vai
ter condição de estar mais tranquilo
para gente bater esse papo aí a mãe
doutora eu queria falar com você sozinha
foi tudo bem a gente pode do seu desejo
a gente pode conversar tá você quer
tirar algumas dúvidas a menina saiu aí
ela eu tenho certeza doutora meu filho
nunca teve relação com ninguém será que
sou eu que nem hiv e passei para ele era
criança olha muito difícil seu filho já
tem 16 anos 16 anos vivendo com o vírus
sem tratamento ainda mais vindo de
criança não é o natural mas como aqui um
teste de hiv para senhora fazer né não
vamos ficar na dúvida mas eu acho pouco
provável ele não quis contar o que
aconteceu mas você já falou de hiv que
seu filho alguma vez não nunca ah não
mas a gente fala para usar camisinha
falei você me jura que seu filho não tem
relação sexual e você me disse que falou
para mim
e olha conversa entre vocês quando vocês
voltarem aqui na próxima consulta vocês
me falam se tem mais alguma coisa que
vocês querem contar e assim foi o rapaz
começou a tomar as medicações com 15
dias ele retornar e aí a mãe pediu para
entrar sozinha de novo tá tudo bem vou
conversar com a senhora antes mas depois
ele entra aí ela entrou e falou ele que
pediu para eu falar com você for é o que
que ele pediu para senhora me contar ele
teve uma relação desprotegida assim foi
a primeira relação da vida dele ele
encontrou uma pessoa por meio de
aplicativo um outro homem combinaram de
se encontrar no terminal de ônibus
depois da escola e ele foi para casa
dessa pessoa onde tinha outras pessoas
lá com a mesma finalidade e ele teve
essa relação pela primeira vez na vida
ele tava com vergonha de me contar
primeiro por questão de ser homossexual
o mundo pela questão de me contar uma
coisa que ele ficou com vergonha mesmo a
primeira relação sexual falar com a mãe
complexo e como é que fala com pai se é
homossexual eu entendi perfeitamente
como que o menino se sentiu ali foi não
tudo bem eu sabia que tinha algo na
história aqui era um gap e meu exame tá
negativo ah tá ótimo beleza chama lá seu
filho esse que ela chamou eu comecei a
falar com ele novamente e aí como é que
foram esses 15 digital entrei na
internet e tudo que tinha sobre hiv na
internet fazer rei aí olha aquilo que
você falou é verdade eu não vou morrer
disso
hoje eu não preciso ter doença e tem que
tomar o meu remédio e tem eu já
conversei com meus amigos na escola
sobre isso você contou para os seus
amigos que você tem hiv não não precisei
contar não mas um dia que tava lá na
hora do intervalo e tal aí também tem
com ele não pois é pulando você sabe que
tem esse tal dessa doença aí esse hiv
tal né tava olhando na internet o
pessoal da nossa cidade que pega como é
que é eu falei ah que legal bacana e aí
depois disse o tempo passou a mãe aliás
antes de sua mãe inclusive me contou que
contaram para o pai sobre a questão da
homossexualidade os pais eram de uma
igreja evangélica eu pensei que seria um
choque muito grande mas por incrível que
pareça não eles acolheram muito bem o
menino e depois de um ano quase dois aí
eu falei com ele assim olha a gente não
teve a conversa de seis meses mas
podemos ter conversa de um ano e meio
agora e aí que que você me diz lá do seu
primeiro dia
e olha doutora as pessoas pegam hiv
porque elas não sabem que ele existe eu
achei que ele estava muito longe de mim
que aquele era só uma coisa que eu
estudava na escola aí a mãe é eu achava
que isso era coisa de gente assim mais
adulta que tinha muita relação com muita
gente diferente nunca imaginei que
pudesse pegar na primeira vez que tem
uma relação com alguém e mas isso mudou
mudou meu pensamento hoje eu até comento
de vez em quando lá na minha igreja que
ela tem que tomar cuidado com jovens tem
que falar com ele sobre isso e assim foi
aí ele já tinha feito prova do enem
tinha passado estava começando os
estudos dele na faculdade inclusive
agora ele vai tá acabando aconteceu dele
a super bem hoje ele tem um namorado os
12 super bem o namorado é negativo ele
tá indetectável ele não transmite para o
namorado dele não admite e consegue
dentro do grupo que eles estão inseridos
falar sobre isso
e a sua sorologia então é uma pequena
experiência de um dia de consultar a mas
essa história se repete toda semana tá
toda semana vai ser alguém e esse aqui
em vitória tá gente né lá em são paulo
que tem muitas para ser consultado por
mim não é aqui em visitaram com a
quantidade de pessoas que moram aqui no
nosso estado vem gente de longe para cá
toda semana eu atendo pelo menos um
menor de idade mas adolescente quase né
com 16 17 anos todo homem quanto mulher
que pela primeira vez se relacionou e
pegou hiv porque ninguém nunca falou
disso com eles então quando eu falo que
o nosso preconceito ele existe ele é de
verdade ele tá aqui sentado junto com
cada um de vocês e comigo também porque
tem coisas que eu não conheço que eu
tenho preconceito
é a mais pura verdade mais cristalina a
verdade é um sonho todo dia pessoas lá
na minha mesa no khan que não vem buscar
o remédio mandar outra pessoa porque tem
vergonha de pegar o remédio alguém ver
que ele tá lá na fila para pegar remédio
de hiv não passou aqui não pedem
dispensa no trabalho tá ville consultar
e aí painel tratamento porque fico com
vergonha de pedir um atestado e qual o
chefe pede para colocar lá os ide e o
cid é de hiv
bom então mal preconceito atrapalha o
controle de uma doença que tem
tratamento que tem muito perto de tua
cura eu não vim falar de cura mas sim já
antecipa para vocês a gente tá muito
perto disso mas que se eu não acabar
hoje com preconceito e com as quatro
doenças eu nunca vou conseguir erradicar
nenhuma delas nenhuma delas a gente
precisa de mais empatia a gente precisa
estar mais no lugar do outro para que
não seja amanhã eu vou qualquer um de
vocês o meu filho ou minha sobrinha ou
não irmão porque quando a conversa sobre
uma coisa que eu conheço aquela coisa eu
deixo de ter medo das pessoas e passa a
ter cuidado comigo mesma
e obrigado quebrar o preconceito é a
chave para resolver boa parte das
doenças infecciosas no mundo todo
incluindo doenças por vacina em pau
quando o assunto é hiv sim mas
precisamos falar sobre isso
[Aplausos]